probably the thing that's most on my  mind right now like [ __ ] man I have to  do this for me and humanity like that's  how big of an ego I have to stay alive  for a long time so I can see this  through I know I'm on to something so  fundamentally different and I know that  I can inspire people to do it cuz it's  gonna have the Empire part to see that's  what people don't get the reason I'm  gonna win is because I've got both the  honey part means that you want to go  change the world the Empire part means  you'll do it at all costs I'm neither  it's cool it's really interesting  because when I buy the Jets there's  gonna be a lot of nice people that are  13  they're gonna think they can build a  nice big business thing do it the right  way I'm gonna redefine what an  entrepreneur and business person is  thought of I think I can do it